[Music]
hello everybody good morning and welcome
to the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences I'm Tom shirk president of
the Academy this morning we will share
the news we've all been waiting for
I'm very happy to be joined by one of
last year's best actress nominees
Jennifer Lawrence the 2011 nominees for
Best Performance by an actress in a
supporting role are bérénice Bejo in the
artist Jessica Chastain in the help
Melissa McCarthy in bridesmaids Janet
McTeer in Albert Nobbs an Octavia
Spencer in the help Jennifer for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role the nominees are Kenneth Branagh
and My Week With Marilyn
Jonah Hill and Moneyball Nick Nolte in
warrior Christopher Plummer in beginners
and Max von Sydow and Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close for Best Performance by
an actress in a leading role the
nominees are Glenn Close and Albert
Nobbs
Viola Davis the help Rooney Mara in The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo Meryl Streep
in the Iron Lady and Michelle Williams
in my week with marylin the nominees for
Best Performance by an actor in a
leading role are Demian Bichir in a
better life George Clooney in The
Descendants
Jonesy Jordan in the artist Gary Oldman
and Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy and Brad
Pitt in Moneyball for best achievement
in directing Michelle Asin Avishai chose
for the artisan Alexander Payne for The
Descendants Martin Scorsese for you go
Woody Allen for Midnight in Paris and
terrence malick for the Tree of Life for
Best Original Screenplay the nominees
are Michelle hasn't a vicious for the
artist an emo mellow and Kristen Wiig
for bridesmaids JC Shandor for margin
call Woody Allen for Midnight in Paris
and a scarf for dolly for a separation
for adapted screenplay we have Alexander
Payne nat faxon and jim rash for the
descendents John Logan for you go George
Clooney
grant Heslov and beau Willimon for eyes
of March Steve Zaillian Aaron Sorkin and
Stan Shevin for Moneyball and Bridget
O'Connor and Peter strong for Tinker
Tailor Soldier Spy for best foreign
language film we have from Belgium
bullhead from Israel footnote from
Poland in darkness from Canada once year
Lazar and from Iran a separation for
Best Animated Feature Film the nominees
are a cat in Paris Ilan gone Yeol and
Jean Loup philic Olli Chico and Ravi and
Rita
Fernando Schwab a and Xavier Moscow
Moscow
Kung Fu Panda 2 Jennifer yuh Nelson Puss
in Boots Chris Miller and Rango Gore
Verbinski and finally I'm pleased to
announce that the film selected as Best
Picture nominees for 2011 are War Horse
Steven Spielberg and Kathleen Kennedy
producers the artist Thomas Lange man
producer Moneyball Michael De Luca
Rachel Horovitz and Brad Pitt producers
the descendants Jim Burke Alexander
Payne and Jim Taylor producers The Tree
of Life nominees to be determined
midnight in paris Letty Aronson and
Stephen Tannenbaum producers the help
Frandsen Greene and Chris Columbus and
Michael bar Nathan producers Hugo
Graham King and Martin Scorsese
producers and Extremely Loud and
Incredibly Close Scott Rudin producer
please join us on February 26th when we
celebrate the magic of the movies thank
you thank you
[Music]